good evening we start tonight with a
developing story that we've been
tracking for months
involving jorge gomez thanks for joining
us here at five i'm denise valdez good
evening i'm brian loftis now he is the
man who was shot and killed at a protest
by metro police last year
lawyers for his family say they have new
video showing
officers allegedly using excessive force
oracle mana joining us now live from the
federal courthouse downtown with the
details and also how metro is responding
tonight marco
denise and brian this all stems from a
black lives matter protest
last summer that happened here near the
federal courthouse
where jorge gomez was shot and killed
family attorneys holding a press
conference here earlier today
on what would have been gomez's 26th
birthday
the attorneys say the videos they
released today contradict the account
given by metro police about that chaotic
night
but it's still hard to tell from this
video what exactly happened metro has
said that gomez raised a rifle toward
officers before they shot him 19
times but attorneys claim although gomez
had a gun he did not
point it toward police adding that
openly carrying a gun was his
constitutional right
attorneys further claimed that gomez was
just trying to go home
after the protest lawyers for gomez's
parents filed a civil rights lawsuit
against the officers involved
ryan fryman dan emerton vernon ferguson
and andrew locker and they just added a
fifth officer john sue who they say
fired non-lethal rounds at gomez before
he was killed
what we're alleging is that he's
responsible
he's the one that set this the chain of
events in motion
right he used unnecessary or excessive
force against jorge
he was robbed of his 26th birthday and
every single one after that we won't be
able to give him hugs anymore
and he gave the best hugs in a statement
to 8 news now metro police said in part
quote the surveillance video released
today by the gomez family
appears to be the same video that the
lvmpd gave to the family's council
the video was originally obtained by the
lvmpd and is one piece of evidence that
is being evaluated in the ongoing
investigation
family attorneys also say that they want
clark county district attorney steve
wolfson
to file charges against the officers in
this case
reporting live from downtown las vegas
tonight orgomana 8 news now